.
In this presentation, we will learn the division of the polynomials
At some time these are called long division
But you'll see what I'm talking about
When we solve some examples
Let's assume I want to divide 2x + 4
On 2
We do not change the value
But change how the value is explained
If we already know how to simplify it
We have done this in the past, we can divide rugs
And set up on 2, thus
How much is this?
This equals x + 2 - let me type it this way--
Equals - if this is divided into 2--
Equals x
Divide 4 on 2, you get 2
If you divide 2 by 2, you get 1
If this equals x + 2, this is
Very direct on what I think
The other way is that you can extract the common factor 2 from here
These are then deleted
But I will also show you how to solve it using the long algebraic division
Which is exaggerated on this issue
But I want to make it clear to you that he does not give us
Something new
It is not only a new way, but it is useful
In more complex matters
So you can also write this as (2x + 4) 2 2
How much is outside the division?
You can do this the same way you would
In traditional long division
You will say 2 - always start with the upper class -
The upper grade 2 2
The 4 will ignore
How much output 2x 4 4?
Well, 2 2 2x = x and put
The x in the x position
x x 2 = 2x
It will now be presented, as in traditional long division
You will now be presented
So how much output is 2x + 4 - 2x?
It's 4, is not it?
Then how much output 4 2 2?
Equals 2, positive 2
Put it in the position of constants
2 x 2 = 4
Ask, the rest be 0
Perhaps this seems exaggerated
For this matter you already know how to solve it
You solve it in several steps
Now we will see this
A generalizable process
You can do this with multiple borders of any degree divided
On a multi-boundary of another degree
Let me explain what I'm talking about
Let's assume we want to divide x + 1 by x ^ 2
+ 3x + 6
What do we do here?
If we look at the upper term statement here, it is
x, and look at the upper term statement here
X ^ 2
You can ignore everything else
This in fact simplifies the process
You say how much x x 2 is divided by x?
Well, x ^ 2 x x = x, right? x ^ 2.
x = x
Put it in the x position
This is the x status here or
Status x ^ 1
So how much x x (x + 1)?
x x x = x ^ 2
x x 1 = x, if x ^ 2 + x
Now we ask, as we did here
What do we get?
x ^ 2 + 3x + 6 - x ^ 2 - Let me be
Very careful - this is equal to -x ^ 2 + x
I want to make sure that the signal is negative
- Apply to all this
If x ^ 2 - x ^ 2, this is deleted
3x becomes -x
Let me put this reference here
If this is equal to -x ^ 2 - x, let's be clear
We ask all this
3x - x = 2x
Then we lower the 6, or 6 - 0 nil
If 2x + 6
Now, wait for the upper pitch, x and 2x
How much outside divide by 2x on x?
Equals 2
2 x x = 2x
2 × 1 = 2
We get 2 × (x + 1) = 2x + 2
But we will put this out of this
We will ask them
Instead of typing 2x + 2, we can write
-2x + 2 And then we gather them
These are deleted
6 - 2 = 4
How much is the output of 4 x x?
We can say that this equals 0, or you can say that
The rest
4 is the rest
If we want to rewrite x ^ 2 + 3x + 6 / x
+ 1 - Note that this is equivalent to x ^ 2 +
3x + 6 x x + 1, this is divided by this
We can now say that this equals x + 2
It equals x + 2 + rest divided by x
+ 1 + 4 / x + 1
This and that are equal
If you want to make sure, if you want to move from
So to this, what you can do is hit this with x
+ 1 / x + 1 And the two gathered together
If this is equivalent to x + 2
I will multiply it by x +
1 / x + 1
This is equivalent to multiplying by 1
Then we add 4 / x + 1 to this
I did this until I got the same standard place
When you do this, when
You hit two bounds and then add 4 here
You must get x ^ 2 + 3x + 6
Let's solve another issue
It's fun
Let's assume that we have - we want to simplify x ^ 2
+ 5x + 4 / x + 4
If again, we can perform a long algebraic division
We can divide x ^ 2 + 5x + 4 by x + 4
Again, we follow the same process
Look at the words highest in each
How much is x x 2 divided by x?
Equals x
Put it in the x position
This is the status of x
x x x = x ^ 2
x x 4 = 4x
And then of course, we will ask
This is from here
Let's put a negative sign here
And then delete them
5x - 4x = x
4 - 0 = 4
x + 4, then you can see this output
You can say that x + 4 x x + 4 = 1
Or if you do not look at the constants
You'll say, well
How much is x divided by x?
Well, it's 1
+ 1
1 x x = x
1 x 4 = 4
We'll ask them from the top, so they'll be deleted
We have no rest
If this simplifies to - this
Equals x + 1
There are other ways you can follow
You can try to analyze the numerator to its factors
x ^ 2 + 5x + 4 / x + 4
This is equivalent to what?
We can analyze this raster to (x + 4)
× (x + 1)
4 × 1 = 4
4 + 1 = 5, all divided by x + 4
These are deleted and we have x + 1 left
Whatever method we follow will succeed, but the long division
You will always succeed, even if you can not delete
The factors are so, even if you have the rest
In this case, we have no rest
This was equal to x + 1
Let's solve another issue so make sure you are
- Because this is very useful
Get it in the tools
Let's assume that I have x ^ 2 - call me
Change it--
Let's assume that I have 2x ^ 2 - I can make this
Setting up quickly -
2x ^ 2 - 20x + 12 - - In fact, let's
Make it interesting, so make it clear to you
Always succeed
I want to move to a higher word than Quadrature
So let's assume that we have 3x ^ 3 - 2x ^ 2 + 7x
- 4, and we want to divide it by x ^ 2 + 1
I have done this on top
But we can do a long division in order to
We find the output or what
Simplify this
x ^ 2 + 1 divided by all these at the top, ie 3x ^ 3
- 2x ^ 2 + 7x - 4
Again, look at the phrase upper score
How much is the divide by 3x ^ 3 on x ^ 2?
Well, it's 3x
We multiply 3x by this, we get 3x ^ 3
Outside the division it is 3x
So we have to write 3x here in x position. if
Outside the division is 3x, so
Now let's hit
3x × x ^ 2 = 3x ^ 3, is not it?
(3x × x ^ 2) + (3x × 1)
If we have here 3x
I make sure it is positioned in x
We will ask them
What do we get?
What do we get when we do this?
These are deleted
We have -2x ^ 2
Then 7x - - because I've subtracted 0 from here -
7x - 3x = positive 4x, we have -4
Again, look at the phrase upper score
x ^ 2 and -2x ^ 2
-2x ^ 2 x x ^ 2
= -2
-2, put it in the status of constants
-2 × x ^ 2 = -2x ^ 2
-2 × 1 = -2
Now, we'll ask that from there, so
Let us hit them with 1, or
This becomes positive
These are deleted
4x - 0 = - Let me change the colors - 4x - 0 = 4x
-4 - -2 or -4 + 2 =
Then x ^ 2, now these have a score higher than 4x, and
The upper class here, so we consider it as the rest
We consider it as the rest
If this phrase we can rewrite it to be equal to
3x - 2 - these are the 3x - 2 - + rest
Ie 4x-2, all divided by x ^ 2 + 1
x ^ 2 + 1
I hope you found this presentation enjoyable